hey guys what's up this is this is my
first ever YouTube live video I do a lot
of Facebook lives but this is my first
ever YouTube live I got some massive
announcements today super excited week
basically what happened Amanda what
happened we we found that she was
pregnant
well she's good news that's the good
news there's some downside right
downside is tonight we're going to
Africa well we were going to go I booked
a flight to go and meet up meet up with
Robert Kiyosaki but in a lot of charity
work out there I'm taking like ten
people some of my success students and
stuff Mandy was gonna come super excited
but uh can't come so that's really
really good Inc but hey this is one of
those things I'd rather do that than not
take the chance
Alan Nelson what is up my man thank you
for the congratulations message however
we've had your birthday celebration
today you it was good your birthday in
South Africa and stuff where we're gonna
be shopping all that so and you got your
nose in your bag which is cool and a few
other bits and bobs so I think I've just
heard my brother arrive I'll introduce
you to him CEO of the SL group so we're
literally going to be leaving for the
airport in just a couple of minutes
Russell are you in the house hey I'm
doing a YouTube live this is my brother
Russell Anna
Anna's also works full-time in on the
business so you can watch Africa and
it's your first time to Africa right
yeah proper Africa Asia yeah we went to
Tunisia but first time to proper Africa
they're gonna be out literally living in
the bush you're not dressed for the bush
man what are you wearing what it's Miami
series we're gonna be sleeping in the
bush digging Wells building water tanks
that's not appropriate for the bush or
for meeting up with Robert Kiyosaki but
there we go so I'm trying to get a date
prepared I've decided that I am gonna do
the challenge of becoming financially
free I'm gonna do it but I just need to
get a date because I got so many travels
because the money can't make this trip
she wants to go to New York so we're
gonna be going to New York in September
for a week or two we're spending the
whole of December in Japan that's the
plan so we just need to get done
I'm thinking maybe next month I'm not
really sure but with all the crash
courses that I've got going on and also
you know all the trips it's going to be
tough I need at least a month I reckon
not going to become four I'm actually
free in a few weeks but I need to give
it give at least a month gap well I'm
not travelling to give me time if I
don't do it I failed which would be
really bad but there's always learning
and failure so that's what we're doing
that's what's up I'll be shooting more
videos also got a ton of content videos
coming out interviewed some absolute
experts lease option agreement bills
buying and refinancing serviced
accommodation we're sort of the serviced
accommodation king we've got a whole
bunch of products coming on so exciting
times I hope you're having a good week
as well just comment below let me know
what you have your weeks going and
what's going on Monday usually people
feel impressed on a Monday I feel pumped
on a Monday because Monday is the day
where we get things done Monday I'm
alive
so take that it okay having a great day
let me know is going on in your week
I'll be doing more videos real soon and
awesome god bless